arts work after artwork finds a buyer
visitors to the affordable art fair in
London aren't exactly dainty about
getting their hands on the goods the
prices between 50 and 5,000 euros per
item are affordable for many people
we have a very Georgian house with gold
mirrors so that would be a perfect fit
I've had a modern picture for an old
house this selection of ours on offer I
think it's the the most impressive thing
I'm having a little bit of difficulty
making a decision we bought two pieces
already and we're looking at a third
yeah more than a hundred galleries are
exhibiting works at the fair the
atmosphere is relaxed with music and
wine making it easier for you to part
with your money fifteen years ago we'll
Ramsey founded the affordable art there
to open the art market to a wider
audience let's try and break down this
preconception that you have to know
about art to buy it this barrier that
stops people going into a gallery we put
the emphasis on the visitors choosing
rather than me the gallery owner here
art is defined by what people like these
three-dimensional pictures and maps are
the work of Christiania Williams the
Icelander living in London also creates
delicate masks she and her three
assistants design materials for her own
label as well as for paul smith and
chanel the affordable art fairs very
good christmas within a certain price
range so i think it's hugely important
in terms of like introducing people are
otherwise slightly you know scared of
buying the first piece of art there's a
very comfortable place to go and and by
which for me personally so it's very
well
the works of Christiania williams
combine art craft and design her sales
channels are pretty varied too she's not
only represented at the art fair by her
gallery she also has an online shop and
sells over the rise art platform I think
it is really good to have a site where
you're able to get a good selection
quite rated something that recommends
different venues like there you're able
to borrow the artwork before you decide
to buy it the London start-up rise art
has more than 20,000 items to choose
from layers of filters help buyers find
what they want and for how much
collectors who want to can set up their
own profile founder Marcus stabber link
wants to reach different target groups
one type of customer there is basically
looking for great art to complement
their interior decoration or their house
you know as they as they invest more
into that living experience and then we
also have a bit more collectors because
we have art ranging from all the way
from fifty pounds up to like 50,000
pounds resort also has pieces by famous
artists such as damien hirst for example
this limited edition of his spot etching
cine o logos for fifteen thousand euros
but most of the work on sale goes for
under a thousand euros like Kevin
Dutton's photographs of plants which are
available on the online platform and at
the fair
the online gallery it's an excellent
place to once you've made the decision
to buy an artist's work perhaps choose
which one you want but I think places
like this where you can see the art on
the wall for me I think that is still
essential whether online or offline
traditional definitions of art are
growing blurred fine art pop culture
designer furniture and sculpture hear
the opinions of art critics are no more
important than those of the visitors
when it comes to deciding don't worry
about what other people are going to
think don't worry about whether it's
going to be a good investment if you
love it then buy it it's a convincing
idea well normally I found a
photographic think about it for ten
minutes and then go back afterwards just
trying to get my husband to get the
wallet out whether in London New York
Hong Kong or Hamburg the Affordable Art
Fair has become a global phenomenon one
that shows that art lovers don't have to
go to museums to get what they want
you